-Guys, it's Friday,
and that's usually when I write
my weekly thank-you notes.
I was wondering if I could
do that right now.
Do you guys mind?
-Yeah.
-We do.
-Yes.
-We don't.
-We do. We do.
-No, we don't.
-We do!
-So, can I can some
thank-you note writing music,
please, Frannie?
[ Piano plays tender tune ]
Oh, perfect.
First picture, please.
Thank you, Oscar pools,
March Madness brackets,
and my taxes,
for being the three times a year
I fill out paperwork solely
through guessing.
♪♪
One more time, Fran.
Thank you, Michelle Obama,
for debuting
your new Netflix show,
"Waffles & Mochi," this week.
And tune in next week
for Melania Trump's
new Netflix show,
"Waffles & Mochi."
[ Laughing ]
♪♪
-You forgot about the picture.
-Oh, yeah.
Show the next.
Yeah, that was
"Waffles & Mochi."
Thank you.
Good job, Winnie.
♪♪
Thank you, Frannie.
Twice, even.
♪♪
-Frannie --
-Thank you,
new study that three feet
of distance is enough
to keep students safe,
but to be extra safe,
all first graders
are still advised
to get a cootie shot.
-What's a cootie shot?
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Puffs ]
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Go, Winnie.
Go, Frannie.
-I did this.
-Do one more, Winnie.
♪♪
Thank you, the president's
Help is Here" tour,
or, as most people
are calling it,
"Biden Better Have My Money."
[ Laughs ]
That's a song.
Based off a song.
Frannie.
Having fun?
♪♪
Thank you -- Go, Win.
-Go? Wait, what?
-Yeah, you can tap.
Thank you, ribbons,
or, as I like to call you,
balloon leashes.
♪♪
Lost Frannie.
Thank you,
new Heinz condiments --
go, Winnie --
Hanch, Wasabioli, and Tarchup,
for sounding like the name
of Iceland's
number-one personal injury firm.
Oh, injury law firm.
I was distracted by the silence.
-[ Laughs ]
-You good?
Thank you, pogo sticks,
for being --
Frannie, still helping?
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Tap, tap, tap, tap.
That's a little dig.
-Yep.
-That's very Frannie, yep.
-Thank you, pogo sticks,
for being
jackhammers that
just want to have fun.
-[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Go, Winnie.
Thank you, puzzles, for being
the slowest way possible
to download a picture.
[ Thrumming music
joins piano tune ]
[ Laughs ]
-What are you doing?
[ Laughing ]
-Stop.
-Just --
-Thank you,
hot chocolate fanatics --
[ Laughter ]
Go, Winnie.
hot chocolate fanatics,
or, as I like to call you,
cocoa nuts.
♪♪
[ Chuckle ]
Final -- last one.
Winnie, last one.
[ Piano plays tender tune ]
There you go.
-What?
-Yeah.
-This one?
-Yeah, perfect.
Thank you, salad,
for not being called
"wet leaves."
There you have it, everybody.
[ Laughing ]
Those are my thank-you notes.
Thank you so much to my helpers.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
♪♪